من طرابلس انضم الينا مراسله صباح العربيه
رينو دويرينا اهلا بك يسعد صباحك تنورينا
دائما بوجودك معانا عارفين عربيكه
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين نعم
بالفعل يعني بعد سنوات من العمل في
اختصاصها تركت ريبيكا مجال التسويق
والاعلام وعادت الى مدينتها طرابلس تشق
طريقا مختلفه دعونا من الاطاله والتعرف
على ريبيكا واعلى قصتها الفريده صباح
الخير ريبيكا اليوم من الوظيفه الى المهنه
الحره وليس اي مهنه الحلاقه للرجال خبرينا
اكثر هي صارت الخبريه انه كنت اشتغل انا
بالتسويق مثل ما بتعرفي واا كنت عايشه
ببيروت وصارت الازمه بلبنان وطلع على
الدولار مره في مجال همم يبقى هناك يعني
صارت خساره اكثر ما انه همم تكون مرتاحه
يعني
تشتغل شغل انا اوريك
فقررت اعملها وبلشت فيها تقريبا
بدرجه الاولى
وانت ايضا ابن ابن ابن بنت مدينه محافظه
الى حد ما يعني كيف كانت ردود الفعل على
هذا الخيار المهني
المتحوله اللي عملتيهن يعني رده فعل انا
اول ما بلشت اعملها فكرت كثير انه اكيد
حتاخذ طابع سيء بالنسبه للناس
جيني دعم كثير من الناس اللي قريبين مني
يعني انا قبل ما درست ان الصوره رايكم اذا
باعمل هيك همم جنه تشجيع كثير وقتها بلشت
همم
ونزلت على الطريق وبلاش اشتغل حسيت كثير
العالم كانت يعني يمكن اول مره بترابلس
هالقد قضيه او قصه مثل هذه بتاخذ طابع
اجابه صحيحه انت اليوم
يعني انت اليوم ما عندك
صالونك بيبي بيوتن قد ايه هذا الشيء ممكن
يعرضك
يعني مرات يمكن للتحرش بالمره او همم اي
شكل يعني من اشكال ال همم
يعني انا شويه ماشي من باتجاه نروح عند
الرجال الكبار بالعمر من بعد تعرفي في قطع
كهرباء كثير في عالم عيشه في طوابع عالي
ما بيقدروا ينزلوا اييه بروح اكثر عن
الاولاد الصغار مثلا الام بتتصل فيه بتقول
لي مثلا عندها ولدين ثلاثه بروح بقص لهم
موفر علي وقت ووفر علي اكيد مصاري لانه
انا باخذ اقل من انه يكون فاتحه محل اليوم
يعني ما تصير تلاقيت اي دعم من الحلاقين
رجلين
منافسه بهذا المجال
اكيد في في منافس اليوم في كثير ناس بدها
تقص لنا بنبسطوا بهالشغله بس همم انا
الحلقتين رجاليه ماسنجر
انقلد مين بين صالون زهره وبين صالون
ريبيكا ومين احسن من مين كمان
نادين انا من زحمه الطريق ما وصلت لاخر
سؤال بدك تساليها من شو يعني بين بين
صالون زهره وبين صالون ريكا ايهما افضل
نادين عم تسالك بعدين صالون زهره بمسلسل
نادين نجيم وبين سنور بيكا ايهما افضل
للبنان عندك صبيان نجمه استيلهم عند ربكه
ههه
وامهم معهن هل انت بتفكري تقصي للنساء
ايضا يعني لا ابدا ااه لانه نساء شويه
يعني كثير عندهم متطلبات وكثير بينقوا همم
كثير فيكي في بعض القصاص يعني
التعامل معه بكثير صراحه
همم اليوم هل تعرضت لشكل من انواع التحرش
كامله كل يوم تقصد زبائن للبيوت وهيك صار
شيء عم بترابلس
السؤال بس صراحه ولا مره لهلا وحتى يعني
بالنسبه للشباب تيجي تقولي بين ال- همم ال
18 والاربعين او 45 اذا ما بعرفهم شخصيا
او ما حدا قائل لي عنه انا ما بطلع لعندهن
يعني انا اكثر شغلتين للكبار بالعمر
للاطفال اكيد اصحابي قريبين اللي بيعرفهم
اني انا ما شفته اكيد بصوا اللون بس
ما بعرف ما بطلع على البيت بصراحه يعني